por 13 votos a favor y 2 en contra la
corte internacional de justicia ordenó
este miércoles 16 de marzo medidas
profesionales contra el gobierno ruso de
vladimir putin que buscan suspender de
manera inmediata las operaciones
militares que iniciaron en territorio
ucraniano el pasado 24 de febrero esta
orden fue anunciada desde la ciudad
neerlandesa de la aia por la presidenta
de la corte que recordemos es el
principal órgano judicial de naciones
unidas' se trata de la jueza joan
donaghy quien señaló que lo que seguirá
ahora es que ambas partes ni ucrania ni
rusia continúen con acciones que
permitan extender el conflicto y que
eviten que llegue a una resolución se
trata de una orden vinculante por lo que
en caso de que el gobierno ruso decida
no acatarlas o ignorarlas se vería
sometido a un aislamiento mucho más
extendido